Thank you for me. I believe
you fell from the sky when I was climbing the cliff while I was fighting Fiber.Is that so?
I don't know if I'm leaving Yes, Mr. Saten, I
should have thought about it a little more seriously.
I'm 17 years old Special lecture I can't get over it It's
cold and nobody listens to that much
[Music]
Who are you?
I don't mean to
call it an assessment because
of the narrowness of the trip.
Ah, it's already a two-tiered skill, but the a-seat is the usual way of saying, isn't it?
When I stopped by a certain player's fort, there was a starry sky, and
I chased after the horse with the green onions, but there's no reason I could catch
up
.
I put my ID card in the cloak that I put on my pneuma,
so it's not in the original,
right?